you can have these protests and stuff
like that and everything's yay rah-rah
here's my side this is my cause
but the moment that somebody goes lord
of the flies
it things just fall apart and it's
explain that i don't know that
maybe there's a lord of the flies is a
book where a bunch of kids end up on a
deserted island again okay okay
i don't want to give away what happened
poor piggy all right piggy um but
basically
you know you you have people who have a
good idea good intention to go into
these areas but
when the chaos happens i mean even
people with the best intentions can turn
on a dime and that's obviously what we
saw in kenosha
uh it wasn't just the individuals who
were involved
the moment that those gunshots went off
i mean you can hear the entire crowd
everybody's hysterical yep and in those
kind of situations that's when all
reason goes out the window
you know you know what's really funny
about that when i was in ferguson
every a funny weird not funny okay okay
what's what's what's what's weird about
this is that
when i was in ferguson or no maybe funny
is the better word not like we want to
take you to revel in it but
the people in ferguson didn't get
hysterical when gunshots went off they
were they were used to it
so the first time we heard gunshots go
off they they'll hit the floor
and then everybody waits and looks
around slowly starts getting back up and
moving to the sides
they didn't freak out they didn't scream
they didn't run attacking people because
they're used to it that's so weird
they knew how to act because they had
experiences before
but in these ride situations you have
people who
freak out what's happening i have no
idea ah
you're yelling i'm yelling loud noises
pirates just people go nuts
and that that's actually describes
pretty well how it was when i was in
santa monica so i think at the same time
there was
uh dc lafayette square
mm-hmm was like that was on fire down
the jackson
yeah and i think at the same time there
was santa monica and there was
fairfax that same weekend but that's how
i was i got there and the first time i
heard the loud
you know shot from the beanbag guns and
all that kind of stuff i you know i
would literally jump
uh by the time i got to kenosha and you
can see the footage on my twitter
i'm walking very calmly uh between
flash bangs and like all this stuff my
back is literally to
these you know militarized police
explosions are happening in front of me
and it's like
you know it you know i got used to it
that's a militarized police
you know we've had a lot of
conversations about that i think it's
the wrong way to describe it
yeah yeah it's weird because we often
it's like an activist talking point
almost
there they're not they're using they're
they're using bean bags
you know and they're using pepper balls
it doesn't even hurt these people that's
not really militarized they're referring
to them yeah
i i could see that being the wrong sure
yeah no i just mean like you know
because we talked about inaccurate
no no i think it's just it was a
colloquial term people used because it
looked
like when i was in anaheim like
we had the local police wearing full
like military style camo
and they had rifles with live ammo and
they were riding around on the sides of
these suvs
so i guess that made sense but now they
keep saying militarized over and over
again and it's like
these cops are wearing plastic armor
with pepper balls
like you're going to get hurt i guess
but it's like
they're less less dangerous than a
regular beat cop you don't
know what yeah it's interesting you say
that too because after the shooting in
kenosha
like they didn't respond like the police
were literally 200 yards away
but well they didn't know what was going
on well i know but i'm just saying in a
normal
a normal scenario with normal control
they hear a bunch of shots and
they run over and this is no this is
important point because when when kyle
rittenhouse put up his hands and walked
past the police all these leftists were
like
oh look he just killed these people and
then he gets to walk away and it's like
it's because these police are actually
less prepared for that kind of situation
than a regular run-of-the-mill beat cop
walking down the street
so when you get a guy a cop in his car
and he pulls someone over
that cop's got a gun with bullets in it
and if he gets scared he shoots somebody
we don't we don't like that we don't
like we don't like when that happens
but when the riot cops come out they
have batons and they have less lethal
weapons
so if you're like has an active shooting
they'll be like we are not equipped to
actually deal with that
so you'll need the regular cop and the
squad car with their body armor and
their you know their handgun to actually
confront something like that
they don't understand this militarized
police they describe
sure apcs and stuff like that but what
we watch when we watch riot police
these cops have more options but can do
are it's less lethal literally less
lethal than a run-of-the-mill you know
patrol cop
do they have armor personnel carriers
they did yeah they did
do they have mounted machine guns on
them no no no no no no no no
they pop out and they fight with the
less lethal though i have to commend dhs
because when i was in portland at the
multnomah justice center i was across
on the on the grass there's the statue
and stuff but i was trying to film and i
had a little umbrella and i was hiding
behind the umbrella
and they started shooting through the
umbrella hit me in the chest and i ran
across the lawn and they hit me
everywhere you were telling me the
umbrella didn't stop the
mind-blowing crazy it's mind-blowing
yeah you would think that a goodwill
umbrella
would stop something like that so the
umbrella phalanx
yeah they watch they watch if they
watched videos of hong kong
you know and that's what it was yeah by
the way did you guys see the four
democratic hong kong lawmakers were
dismissed
no no i didn't see that it's gone hong
kong we're losing hong kong there's no
hong kong anymore it's just
you might want to look that up that's a
crazy story yeah just go build a chazz
over there
yeah well you know you know what's
really interesting is that i think
with this you know they're gonna do the
lockdown again fauci says do what you're
told
they're talking about you know biden
says dark winter
and uh yeah but i have to wonder i have
to wonder
are the leftists who are anti-fascist
going to come out and protest against
the government that is locking down the
country or are they going to be like
we're going to do as we're told that's a
good question like
what would happen in that i mean what
happens to antifa
could you imagine if like antifa is
finally like stopped and shut down by
the power of fouchy
it's like antibodies going crazy and he
goes do what you're told and they're
like
okay we better go back inside guys you
wonder though do they believe in do they
do they believe it says infectious
clearly they don't clearly they don't
i mean but they all they always wear
masks you know and they come down on you
if you don't they come down on you
you're not wearing a mask and you're too
close from me and you're
you're a super spreader they do that
kind of thing but everyone does that
kind of thing too you notice
you see it on both sides you see it on
both sides super conditioned to follow
instructions
like their young kids they're about our
age and like all they've ever done is
follow instructions
no no but they're going around fighting
with cops and like burning things down
and destroying
instructions they're literally doing
they're literally doing the opposite of
that
and they're getting arrested and going
out there's like nothing stopping them
even when they say you're going to jail
for this
they let them out and they're like i can
do whatever i want with the exception
marquis
love i don't know if you saw this video
marquis love uh
kicked anna hayner in the head after i
mean he was brutally assaulted pulled
from his
xyz um did you film that
yeah he got kicked in the head it was it
was i saw it it was very graphic
he got less i think he got 20 months
which is i mean of all the people that
are that are being prosecuted that's the
one
uh that is making the headlines right
yeah so
you know it's not it's they're not all
getting away with the majority of it
they might as well
might as well all be getting away with
it so if you kick somebody right in the
head
on camera and the entire nation sees it
then you'll get 20 months
20 months attempted murder that was a
full force
he was going for a field goal yeah you
guys think that um
contact lens cameras will help
journalism
do those exist yeah they do i have one
they're pretty advanced
telescopic but i heard about this in
2000 the answer is no
eight yeah you have to be searching your
eyes
the answer is no we tried google glass
didn't work but that's because you could
see the glasses
i'm wondering if they're hidden and they
don't know that you have a camera if
you're going to be safer
or if the cops will think you're part of
the problem you can do we have hidden
cameras now
it did and people use them so use them
i mean we already have we already have
to hide the fact that we're press
because it's one thing if you're like
antifa sympathetic press
but people find out who we are they
follow our twitters or whatever and
they're
antifa and they start just sending our
photos around yeah and saying these
people are here so
we have to disguise ourselves as much as
we possibly can which means dressing up
like antifa which
is getting blasted with pepper balls yes
but people always say that like on
twitter and stuff like oh well you
deserve it and it's like yeah we accept
the risk but
also i'd rather be at the mercy of law
enforcement than at the mercy of a
sucker punch that's coming out of
nowhere
well sorry listen antifa are bad at what
they do
but will kill you yep right so we we've
had a few instances
we had the one that one serious instance
where uh
you know michael reinold he killed that
trump supporter and that's because
that's a dude who actually had a gun
most the time antifa just like you know
dumb young people and they'll have a bat
or something
they'll full force punt you in the head
they'll punch you they'll beat you
they'll really beat you they'll leave
you with messed up teeth like they did
to andy no
but they don't usually have the the
force for a full-on like lethal inc
encounter
but we are starting to see stabbings so
you know we saw some stabbing happen in
dc or whatever yeah uh beverly beatty
was just stabbed and i don't know that
that was antifa or i don't even know who
that was it's a space force
i think right uh his name maybe i didn't
know he stabbed in
portland but there was a guy in portland
who got stabbed what was it so something
rebel or
but but uh the issue is because i feel
bad if if i was if i was told you know
i'm standing between the cops
and antifa i'm walking towards the cops
easy sure the cops
are constrained yeah there are instances
where cops you know this police
brutality
people get shot people get killed but
but cops
are accountable and so i know exactly if
you walk up to the cops the worst end's
gonna happen
you're gonna get marks on your wrists
from being cuffed they're gonna throw
you in a really uncomfortable position
the worst case scenario with antifa i
got billy club pretty good in wisconsin
like a month ago and my knee is still a
little bit messed up but
i'll still take the billy club over i'll
kick to you guys ever play d and d
dungeons and dragons no there's
alignment scales and you'd be lawful
neutral or chaotic
you can be good neutral or evil and you
can kind of mix those two up
cops are lawful neutral they seem to be
antifa's chaotic
neutral and the chaotic they're chaotic
they're not neutral well for the
i think they are i don't think they're
evil i mean i i don't i don't think
they're out there to hurt people
you gotta you gotta they that's what
evil means in dnd what does it mean
well my understanding is that it means
you you act in a depraved way for your
own personal benefit
yeah evil is pretty nasty but even evil
neutral people there may be some that
are like that but it's not every it's
not every single one by the way no but
as a group
yeah they're yeah portland was that guy
evil the guy who stabbed him he knew
what he was going to do he might have
been
yeah i mean i think as a not all of them
are neutral but i would say as
not all cops are neutral some of them
are good some of them are evil but
for the most part you're looking at
lawful versus chaotic and i'd much
rather side on the side of lawful
than chaotic and you always pretty much
always should for the betterment of your
life
i think it's you know there's gonna be
bad apples everywhere it's a matter of
um
what are the structures by which these
people are being kept in check and
and what's the oversight right so people
complain about the fact that our
criminal justice system and our police
don't have enough oversight but
antifa has absolutely zero so i think
you know in any situation like
those bad apples are going to take as
much as they're they're they're given
and so police have a lot more there's a
lot more there to keep them from
acting evil they're accountable and
an antifun and black lives matter likes
to act like they're not accountable but
they are because there are instances
where cops are not being held
accountable does not mean that
all cops all the time are unaccountable
which means
for the most part when i've been
arrested before
and it's it's a process and then i've
you know left the next day or in a few
hours i've also been attacked
by you know antifa and far leftists and
there's no predictive it's unpredictable
they're vindictive they're nasty and
nothing will be done about what they do
to you if they take your stuff you can't
get it back
if you get arrested the cop takes your
phone you can be like the cop took my
phone and then file paperwork and then
eventually you find your phone or they
give it to you when you leave
antifa will steal from you and then run
and laugh like the cops are
um you know they have to appeal to the
law which got accountable to the law the
u.s law which is pretty good law
if we were in turkey or in china the
cops might be the bad guys good luck
yeah i think you're right that there are
obviously problems with the system
and everything can be improved right and
there are definitely issues in
in america with respect to law
enforcement but
people are taking for granted the fact
that the the civil unrest that you saw
elsewhere where the police were using
lethal force in tahrir square i mean
well uh
i don't think the cops were doing
anything to our career yeah that wasn't
i wouldn't call that uh
that was two factions fighting each
other when the military waited until
they like they decided which side they
were on and then it was just shut down
it was over
but they but they did go and just start
mass executing a bunch of the the muslim
brotherhood people oh so there's that
too yeah
that was after the revolution uh they
just started going and just
firing at these people these kids just
like
you know remember the kent state 1970
when the
national guard killed four kids i just
heard about this that was mine
i went to kent state actually what year
was that 1970 may 4th
yeah and it was just the most gruesome
national
global news it was a vietnam protest
four people four dead brothers that's a
big deal
in ohio crosby stills national young
wrote us yeah i think they shot him with
rifles too
right yeah i believe national guard one
dude got like a shot through the wrist
and then like paralyzed his hand or
whatever
yeah and that's a big deal to us in
these other countries they're mowing
down crowds and we've made progress
obviously because
look at all the unrest we had this
summer and and we didn't have police or
national guard actually shooting people
with lethal it's kind of it's kind of
crazy you think about
you know the la riots it was a rodney
king intent
they beat him and he lived and then the
whole city went
just nuts now we have like
people dying and sometimes like nothing
happens
it's like it's kind of weird you know
but it shows that like things are
actually getting better even with the
unrest
so so like the unrest is bad but if
someone died at the hands of cops
there would have been a huge unrest but
people died at the hands of protesters
and there was
no unrest this bothers me immensely
because there should be the same amount
of
unrest whether it's the cops or
protesters protesters seem to get away
with anything
or compare kyle rittenhouse to uh the
killing in
in portland right of the trump supporter
what's his name again who who killed him
michael reinel michael ronaldo yeah and
i mean i'm not
saying i'm not justifying either one
obviously but the press's coverage was
was discernibly different between the
two instances
of course yeah of course and they're and
they're writing stuff like uh
kyle rittenhouse is a mass shooter and
we should be terrified that his
you know trump supporters are you know
uh venerating this man
who's a clear he clearly killed these
innocent protesters
they don't care for nuance they don't
care for you know understanding anything
at all it's just we
want we win our team the rest of you can
burn
so this is to me this is just an
extrapolation of we want
mindset we want we want we want we want
the narrative to be this way
this is the way the narrative is we want
chaz we want this we want this you know
and in chats like what you were saying
we want and they don't produce anything
it's just take take take
they wanted vegan meat replacements
because you know what i mean they can't
they can't feed themselves and they have
to go
outside they have to cross national
borders right
into their entire foreign aid yeah
seriously shaking down local businesses
they have to invade uh the next
thing i think even the little the little
taco shop there that they had a bathroom
you know and of course they changed the
code to
uh i think you know acab and numbers
what is that one three one two yeah
yeah uh just to get on board you know so
so what are we gonna see
this weekend what do you think trump
supporters i was told by the media the
right wing
got to be careful about those trump
supporters yeah man i was enjoying my
uh civil unrest riot vacation
so i'm hoping that things stay peaceful
but with that being said there there are
groups antifa groups that we know of
that are organizing and also
proud boys groups that are organizing so
that's never a good recipe
right um and i mean in dc with that
being said
generally speaking the police the park
police they are
all much much better at managing these
situations than for example the kenosha
police obviously
so they're always like i mean the irony
there is like every weekend they'd shut
down the um the key bridge which is
relative you know a bike ride away so
i'd go down there and just watch them
shut it down
and the irony there is they're they're
chanting all cops are b words
but the cops are shutting down each side
of the bridge to make sure that there's
no car
traffic to make sure that they're safe
so while they're chaining that the cops
are sitting there
watching blocking traffic and then
they're done with their demonstration
and then they
yep that's why the cops it was really
funny i remember being in union square
in new york
and this person was screaming at a cop
you know whose side are you on
you know you're a traitor and all this
stuff and i was like bro that cop
doesn't know anything about what you're
talking about and they don't
care they want to go home after work lay
back in their lounge chair and put on
their dvr of the game
who won the game they're going to watch
it and then tell their friends
too right it's a job yeah exactly they
come home they're stressed they kick
their boots off they lay down and
they're like
and the wife goes like so how was work
today honey and he's like some person
was screaming about the one percent or
something
i don't even know fascists and this and
that and it's like
yeah yeah whatever man if if this you
wouldn't be here you'd be
a mist of some kind if this was fascism
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through
friday at 8pm so come back to check us
out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you